of the algorithms were committed turn
off your pure exploration thanks for
sticking it out until the last joke of
the day so if you you know don't know
what these things mean don't worry about
it really little you know a title of the
talk is you know solving discrete
problems with uncertain data and so so
the uncertainty here and the problems
that we'll be considering will be you
know very different from the previous
talks and basically the problems the
following you know this is the way I
came to this problem so I want to solve
the spanning tree problem the max weight
spanning tree problem all of you know
how to do this so you're given these
weights and with respect to these
weights you want to find an acyclic
subset of edges with maximum weight okay
we know how to do this but now the
problem is that I don't know the weights
the weights are unknown to me and I have
to learn them and how do I learn them so
what's my model I'm given access to your
random variable so for every edge I'm
given an unbiased estimator let's say
that the weights are supported over the
interval 0 1 it's an unbiased estimator
and now I can take a bunch of samples
and at the end of the process after I
take a whole bunch of samples I want to
be able to output the max weight
spanning tree with high probability so
at every point in time I pick my
favorite page I query it and I get you
know one sample from there and I can
take a whole bunch of sample so I can
sample the hell out of this edge I'll
get a very good estimate
but basically I want to find the max
weight spanning tree with high
probability or I want to find an
approximate max weight spanning tree
with high probability so basically this
is the exact identification problem this
is back model and the other problems I
want to study and I want to ask the
question how many samples do I need
is a problem clear and this problem is
you know a generalization of problems
the people have studied for quite some
time in fact people in this room have
studied this for sure
you know you've seen this end of the
stochastic multi-armed bandit problem
where you know you're given an N arms
each arm has an unknown reward you know
reward distribution think of these is
the new eyes and you want to pick the
best one the one with the highest
average and what you do is you pull a
bunch of farms and then hopefully you
can solve several problems in this you
can solve the great minimization what
I'll be looking at is the best arm
identification from find the one which
is the best with high probability and if
you map it back to the previous MST
problem it's a bunch of parallel edges
let's just have two vertices a bunch of
parallel edges and I want to find the
max weight edge right we all happy with
the problems right the previous case you
know which edges of zero weight my grab
it could be a general graph yeah so I
there are some edges that are missing
and I know these edges are there these
edges are missing of course I could put
in edges with you know mean zero just to
you know mess you up
but yeah it's a general graph other
questions you point to an inch you get
to pick I mean sure so I'm using packing
somewhat more you know yeah I'm using it
only in the sense of being probably
approximately correct rather than the
model where you're you know you're given
them yeah
other questions okay so this is the
problem that we want to study and of
course this problems been studied for a
long time it has applications you guys
know about the applications much more
than I do and in fact you know there's
books papers by people in the room I'm
gonna skip over all that but I'm for
sure I'm going to miss a whole bunch of
references see you guys okay but I'm
going to tell you about some things that
you know this is all stuff best arm
identification just this multi unbanded
thing best top k arms find the best 20
arms and this is this is stuff that
mostly prior work this is the stuff that
we were looking at the combinatorial
problem I'm given some combinatorial
structure I want to find you know if you
haven't seen Metroid's wherever you see
matrix just replace spanning trees
you'll be very happy
matchings so find the max weight
matching and then you know a fairly
general problem which I probably won't
get to because I don't want to you know
rush through things you know I'll give
you a partition of n space and I want to
figure out in which part does this mean
vector lie
so this is a very general problem and we
know some results for this there is a
nice open problem here and you know I'll
end out the open problem but basically
let me tell you just a little about this
this might be you know bread and butter
to some some of you but they're cool
results and we can extend these things
well I should have mentioned it too
right at the beginning this is work with
a whole bunch of people who used to be a
Cheng hua ji only Ming the Chao Li
j.chan Andrew somewhere okay so you know
here is the simplest thing you know
uniform sampling I just want to find
best term so I can just sample the hell
out of area and use the turnip bonds in
the Union bond and basically if I take
so many samples then I'll be very close
to the mean and then I'll find an
epsilon approximate arm sonar which is
within epsilon of the maximum with high
probability and all of you know how to
do this right can you do better is the
question and one thing that's known is
the lower bound due to Menaul and it's
sick less and actually a bunch of other
people and I'm probably dropping some
names here which say the following so
the lower bound is kind of nice it
depends on these gaps that we've seen
before even today so if this Delta I is
the gap between the best arm in the eye
at arm then the lower bound says it's
like 1 over Delta s squared
Thanks log 1 over Delta so if I imagine
that the gap between the best in the
second best is epsilon then it's like 1
over epsilon squared log 1 over Delta
summed over all arms so that's n so this
annoying
apart from this this little n out here
we seem to be tight I don't expect you
to you know get this lower bound
immediately but it's not very difficult
in fact I have a proof sketch later on
but you know this one should be clear
please ask questions if
okay okay so of course one can ask the
question can you get rid of the log n
term and out here I was doing uniform
sampling I was just sampling each arm
well enough to get a fairly decent
estimate 1 plus minus epsilon estimate
with uniform sampling you can't do
better
no surprises out there you've seen this
before but here is this cool algorithm
some of you will find this interesting
here's what I'm going to do I'm going to
pull each arm so I'm going to do this in
rounds I'm going to pull the each arm mi
times I'm going to look at the empirical
means and I'm going to drop the lower
half of the amplitude means and I'm
going to half the number of arms I'll do
this until I have a small number of
farms and then I will do just uniform
sampling okay and the reason why this
works is actually very easy
maybe I'll just sketch it very quickly
okay so let's say this is the best term
and let's say that all the other arms
just for simplicity are at least epsilon
away from this guy okay so once you take
one over epsilon squared log 1 over
Delta samples maybe 2 over Delta
whatever this arms estimate
this arms estimate will not fall by more
than epsilon over two let's send
whatever
so this arms estimate is pretty good
there are a whole bunch of arms out here
I can't hope to do a union bound what's
the probability that any fixed arm
actually beats this thing it's like
about Delta over two because of this
kind of thing okay so the expected
number of arms that gunk that's going to
be the best one is about two over Delta
so the probability that n over two of
these guys beat this is only like Delta
over two each one of these is going to
beat this forget the twos all over the
place each of these is going to be the
best turn with probability about Delta
so you expect about Delta of these guys
to lie above the probability that n over
two of these lie above is only like
Delta so basically this guy is going to
lose out with probability at most Delta
in this round he survives the next round
I'm going to what am I going to do I'm
going to half the debt and we're proceed
did that kind of make sense so you know
very simple idea gets you the right
number of samples which is you know a
total of the total number of samples is
n over epsilon squared log K over Delta
Q finding the top k if you finding the
top one that's log 1 over Delta will
match the the manure sit sick list lower
bottom it's very simple very clean idea
so this one is due to have endowed
manure and one soon it will extend it to
top k and then there have been a whole
bunch of work which has been trying to
figure out exactly what is the right
bound in the exact identification case
and this is the kind of mess that you
get into this is very close to being
optimal I'm not going to you know spend
much time on this but I'm just putting
the references you can look it up and
what I can tell you later on ok so
there's a bunch of stuff on finding top
arms in top k was it a question ok you
know how do you prove lower bounds you
prove this via you know change of
distribution arguments as you might
expect and maybe I'm just going to skip
over this part it's actually you know
kind of simple like let me tell you
about how to extend these ideas to
finding let's say spanning trees so
again the same problem you remember that
means and there are n objects out here
so in you know usually we imagine graphs
with M edges just think of these as n
edges the metroid constraints as i said
mate right the spanning trees or
extensions they're off and so we had
algorithms which worked for general
Metroid's and these almost match the
things for best k arm and so here's the
here's the results you can get and you
can see numerically they look very
similar basically n over epsilon squared
log K over Delta which was the best
thing for top K and for exact
identification there's again some mess
but this mess is very similar to the
previous mess so I think you're okay but
here's the algorithm I want you to take
away the algorithm it's actually very
cute because you know it builds on this
very nice idea of David cards so how do
you find a an optimal spanning tree
there are many algorithms but Carter's
algorithm is one of the most beautiful
so here is what he says I want to find
the spanning trees so let's just
randomly sample half the edges and
recursively build a max weight spanning
tree on this thing okay and now you can
use this max weight spanning tree on the
green edges so the remember the green
were the sample subsample the edges and
I'll call the sub sample instead of
sample because I'm sampling for my
learning thing so I don't want you to
get confused your subsampled edges I
build a max weight spanning tree now I
can drop a bunch of edges which can
never be in a max weight spanning tree
any suggestions on which edges I could
drop right off the bat green edges for
sure right but in fact if there's some
cycle and this edge is the lowest weight
edge on that cycle I can drop it no
dozens red rule or something like that
so I can drop a bunch of edges and
beautiful lemma and if I won't strapped
for time I'd actually prove this lemma
to you the beautiful lemma says that the
expected number of edges you'll be left
with is only twice the number of
vertices in the graph I'm assuming that
I'm sampling with 50% probability
actually let me prove this no it's it's
so good example half of the edges
Manning tree recursively on that so I
wanted to compute Mack spanning tree so
a sample subsample half the edges and
now i recurse on that half so i
subsample half the edges I use my own
algorithm I think our girl uses his own
algorithm to recursively build a max
weight spanning tree on these things but
this might not be the global one because
of course this might be the cheapest
edge in the graph you want this but you
didn't subsample it so he built
something and he can use this edge to
throw away whole bunch of other edges
maybe I won't prove it after no way and
so what do we let's let's do it okay so
so what's the argument so the argument
is following I'm going to run kruskal's
algorithm in my mind this is only for
the analysis I'm running kruskal's
algorithm I pick the max weight edge and
then I decide whether to subsample it or
not if this edge was being added by
kruskal's algorithm I say hang on a
minute let me see if it's actually
subsampled or not so I picked the
Kruskal wants to pick this a subsample
with probability 1/2 I drop it they go
to the next edge okay and I keep on
doing this if it's added then I add it
to my recursive little blue graph and if
not I just move on to the next stage now
remember Kruskal is going to add at most
a vortex many the number of vertices
many edges to the graph i'm subsampling
with probability 50% so really I am
looking for how many times will I sample
until I see number of vertices many
heads when I'm subsampling with 50%
probability there's twice the number of
vertices and that's the proof
it's very beautiful and it extends to
Metroid's
seamlessly so what's our algorithm our
algorithm is very simple it's you know
very directly inspired by this sub
sample the subset of edges maybe one
hundredth of the edges it doesn't matter
find a max weight spanning tree over the
sub sample edges you might be making
mistakes because you know there's
uncertainty out here so we left a Union
bound overall the mess get estimates for
the non tree edges by more sampling
lickers the remaining edges the
algorithm you know this is pretty much
the algorithm the analysis is very
similar in spirit to the to the median
sampling technique that I told you about
I'm not going to go into the details but
the main idea was somehow this allowed
us we gave us the combinatorial
structure to get the algorithm to work
questions about this
go so so this works for spanning-tree
this works for these mate relate things
but it doesn't work for matchings it
doesn't work for other combinatorial
constraints and so for some time we were
stuck on this thing we didn't know what
to go and so then we came up with you
know so a bunch of work has been done in
this area and inspired by some other
work as well we came up with you know we
can come up with a per instance lower
bound on the number of samples you need
for a very general combinatorial
structure so we'll I'll show you this
thing on the next slide and then one can
come up with the sampling algorithm
which has complexity which looks like
this okay so what's what are the various
terms this is a lower bound that we came
up with this is the confidence parameter
this is the gap between the best in the
next best structure and this is the
number of objects that we're looking at
so if it was spanning trees this would
be exponential in n you know we can show
that this is required in the worst case
so here it's required in the worst case
this is a sampling algorithm complexity
result there's not a poly time algorithm
I can make this poly time for some
special cases but I won't have time
today to tell you about so basically I'm
going to tell you more or less only
about the lower bound and then we'll
wrap up in them yeah so f is the so I
have this underlying combinatorial
structure so think of this as the number
of spanning trees for the number of
matchings yeah so this is for any
combinatorial abstract combinatorial
structure and the idea of the following
sorry the the points not very clear or
minimize tau is the number of samples so
I want to minimize the total number of
samples I take such that if I look at
the optimal and I look at its mean and I
look at any other set and I look at its
mean then 1 over tau I basically in the
symmetric difference between these two
sets I must take enough samples so 1
over tau I you know this is saying that
the Tawaf must be large enough
and this is true for every set which is
not the optimum I mean if it's the
optimum then there's a trivial bound and
this lower bound so this is what we show
that any algorithm that succeeds with
probability 1 minus Delta requires so
many samples and expectation you know
the proof is not very surprising once
you come up with this idea the proof is
not very surprising basically you take
any algorithm that succeeds with this
probability let ni be the expected
number of samples that this algorithm
takes and then you show that this the
this resulting solution resulting values
form a solution to this thing and the
argument is again a change of
distribution argument what happens if I
change the the means of these set of
arms from this to this and once you
write this lemma so this says if you can
solve this if you can solve this a
convex program is the convex program if
you can solve this then you have a lower
bound and number of samples you need so
of course the challenge is well get an
upper bound which matches this lower
bound to some fudge factors so if you
look like you have a question the gap
the best possible upper bound is this
times this log F and then there is the
log 1 over Delta but that's essential
and there's some log log terms so your
saclink bound is already optimal to
constants
so let me just go back good so the lower
bound is log you know this is the load
bar pretty much and the separately log F
I don't know how to multiply these two
things together and get it you know
Universal load yep
probably can be done I don't know how to
do it okay
so I'll you know pretty much telling you
the challenges you know this is the
lower bound I want an upper bound which
matches this up to this log a factor
maybe how do I do that
of course I don't know how to solve the
math program the math program has these
meals and I don't know the muse of
course I'm going to guess in double
right and this collection F may be large
so I don't know how to solve this in
polynomial time and that I can't do in
general but I can do it for special
cases so basically you know this is the
one thing it's it's a there's a lot of
stuff here but I'm just giving you a
general idea of what the algorithm looks
like and the algorithm is and the log F
should give you an idea the algorithm is
going to eliminate sub optimal solutions
not a poly time algorithm clearly so
what do you do there's a mess if you
only have one candidate remaining you
should make sure that it's good you do
some verification step otherwise in this
iteration you're going to remove all the
guys who are some epsilon are away from
the optimum how you solve a convex
program with this case of epsilon are
you sample things accordingly and you
get rid of all the sub optimal solutions
at a very high level if the idea is very
simple there's some details but this is
you know if you if you take this and you
think about it you should be almost much
of the way there okay let's say LP maybe
I will stop in with just mentioning this
the general problem okay so the general
problems the following I have RN I'm
giving you a subject set of disjoint
regions and what I want to figure out is
I want to figure out the region that
contains the mean vector
how many samples do you need for this so
you can write down a lower bound and the
lower bound again looks like pretty much
this previous one because that was so
general you can come up with this and
the upper bound if we know and this is
you know this is annoying there's a
annoying n cubed term out here and this
is the sort of this is the one that
bothers me the most this and you know
some nth term needs to be lost but I
don't know whether I need so many
samples okay so little Delta is the
confidence so I want to output something
with probability one minus Delta big
Delta is how far the mean vector
actually lies from the boundary of one
of these regions because if it's very
close to the boundary I would need
something like this to get over that
problem so that's pretty much what we
know I don't know a better lower bound I
love if I'd love it if somebody solve
this problem but that's pretty much all
I have today we talked about these you
know a variety of problems maybe too
many but hopefully some of these are
interesting you know they're natural
questions all over the place better
bounds efficient algorithms so I don't
know if I should diagram so many of
these settings and in general you know
you know there's a whole bunch of
optimization problems that we like to
solve
if the data is uncertain how many
samples do I need to solve my problem
I'd love to be able to answer this in
much more generality than I do right now
and that's pretty much all I have this
thank you
[Applause]
probably naive but when you do the last
problem that you tried is some kind of
divide and conquer where you take unions
of these things possibly possibly yeah I
may be right so n is the dimension of
the space it's not the number of these
little pieces out here yeah yeah so I
would have that dependence was not on
the is the dimension of space
maybe I haven't thought about this at
all so they might make perfect sense I
just haven't thought about that
so I have a question when you introduce
the median algorithm you actually you
don't compare everyone to the top one
and then when you actually implement it
for the e-commerce yeah is there is
there not discernible by implementing
the median approach yeah so one of the
things with this sort of median once is
there was this very nice threshold I
could come up with in some sense and I
knew that the number of people who go
above should be small and things like
this but with metroid' structures it
could be that all the really interesting
things are sitting down below so just a
single thresholds not quite the right
answer and maybe you know this this
sample tree is implicitly giving us a
threshold for every particular range but
that's kind of vague
and you can replace it by enzymes
[Music]
maybe I don't know
love one of a itself capital Delta the
Delta is my confident I see using just a
trivial sampling approach possibly
possible yeah it sounds about right
right Rick just not be there absolutely
but that's a good point
all right so we're good over time so
it's the end for Jays